pas tu me dis tu t'amènes avec ta grosse
bayonne sa rolls la rolls royce et le
rend lui à rolle c'est en alberta
il est remonté ça m'a même dit ça c'est
gentil mais non il faut et alors je lui
ai fait je ne peux pas partir en
vacances et ses vacances confie je suis
rentré chez lui et voit une idée me
vient je lui téléphone mon nom j'ai dans
mon bureau j'ai quelques amis et je lui
offre des vacances avec je lui dis j'ai
des amis qui sont en ce temps l'italie
et ils sont été appelés en amérique
d'urgence leur papa est mort une peau
vieillie même qui est mort ça pose est
est là alors ils sont obligés ils sont
obligés de prendre l'avion est de la
partie et la voiture reste à naples et
de naples il faut qu'elle aille jusqu'à
bordeaux pour transiter jets de lave
aller jusqu'à 6 en amérique si la
bienvenue oui jusqu'à bien compris et
d'ensuite d'une arrière compris non
annoncés pour ce site est alors cette
voiture là il faut que moi je dois aller
là prendre un appel à ramener à bordeaux
c'est là l'un est âgé voulez vous le
faire at il dit c'est ce formidable
tunis et une cadillac équipe fabuleuse
saga culture ne dise téléphone et de ce
que vous voulez et origines et c'est
vrai et alors brévelay et en plus je
vous donne cinq cent mille 2 500 mille
lits retrouve au fin de voyage et vous
êtes tous payer les formidables et alors
ils fabriqueront des contrats dont se
sert la main et ils savent à un appli
est entre temps tous et après nous
apprenons immédiatement que cette
voiture est bourré de drogue
elle est bourrée de les pare chocs sont
en or il ya des drones énorme diamant il
ya des les bourrées de deux choses il
faut pour passer la douane encore mieux
aux ballades et ça c'était c'est l'homme
en définitive à la l'histoire ce n'est
pas la voiture qui est suspect c'est
l'homme dents définitives le propos de
funès c'est de trouver un barge cordiaux
que personne au sol qui a un casier
judiciaire absolument vierge et de lui
faire passer la frontière avec sa bonne
mine son casier vizir virgin est
absolument soupçons